la galère continue donc pour des
millions de gens dans toute la france la
paralysie et quasi pas
[Musique]
passat et trois points que sonne jamais
conclure hier soir ils m'ont obligé à
sortir
qu'est ce que c'est que cette riche ya
des dicos n'est pas pas plus moi j'ai un
papa pitt marine tu exagères aussi le
marché aux pays bas pour être alerté
lundi pour j il faudra vraiment décollé
vers 10 heures
on a calculé sais pas comment mais vous
de votre fils vous avez complètement
sorti de la tête tu peux te faire
confiance
un web allemand justement je vous
donnais pas mon cul je fais sans mal la
journée avec la plainte sinon je casse
la vente
c'est une voiture électrique monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bavans
[Musique]
dans un petit patelin pas très loin
d'aix
abbas est sur ma route descend sur la
côte j'ai l'impression que je suis pas
sûr d'être un montage est hélas parce
que j'avais peur de perdre on perd deux
c'est complètement con heures avec eux
comme ça depuis si longtemps mais
parfois beaucoup de toi qu'on me faisait
plus simple
[Musique]